it has finally happened the moment we
have been waiting for in the house
Speaker race no Kevin McCarthy has not
yet won no we still do not have a
speaker but finally after days of
anticipation
someone finally nominated Donald Trump
Trump
Gallagher
McCarthy
Matt Gates absolutely love it and
frankly Donald Trump would be a great
house speaker
for this time in history the only job of
the house Speaker over the next two
years while Democrats hold the White
House and the Senate is to gum things up
for Biden
nobody would do that with a greater a
plum than the Donald the anti-trumpers
would get him out of the 2024
presidential race probably maybe he'd
just run for both the pro trumpers would
get him two heartbeats away from the
Oval Office and most important of all we
would get to watch him make snide
remarks and funny faces at Joe Biden
during the State of the Union Matt Gates
I am soul
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
olshia
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from grip who says
regarding the vote for speaker see how
hard it is to rig an election when
there's no drop boxes and you verify the
identity of everyone who's voting it's
amazing it's so weird
that there's a different set of rules
when the congressmen want to vote than
when we the hoi polloi people get to
vote when the congressman vote there is
definitely election security they know
who's voting that's for sure and they
got the precise numbers and they keep
doing it until they get it right with us
though they don't really take those
kinds of measures it's enough to get
your blood pumping when you want to get
your blood pumping in the morning you
gotta check out Black Rifle coffee right
now go to blackriflecoffee.com use promo
code Knowles Black Rifle Coffee Company
set out on a mission to make the best
cup of coffee to ever fill your mug they
wanted to sell enough premium coffee to
be able to build a support network for
veterans First Responders and law
enforcement thanks to your support that
dream has become a reality this year
alone your support has helped Black
Rifle coffee expand their team of active
duty service members veterans and
Veteran family members they were also
able to donate over 120 000 bags of
coffee to Veterans and First Responders
all thank
to you if you want to continue
supporting this terrific company go to
blackriflecoffee.com and use promo code
nols kwles at checkout for 10 off your
purchase and your first coffee Club
order black raffle coffee is roasted by
a veteran-led team of brilliant coffee
graders here in the U.S the coffee is
truly one of a kind but it's your
support that gets gear funding and
supplies into the hands of those out on
the front lines go to Black
riflecoffee.com use promo code Knolls
kwles for 10 off you can also find Black
Rifle coffee in grocery and convenience
stores near you Black Rifle coffee
America's coffee
also I should wish everybody a happy
January 6th a really really wonderful
day obviously it's wonderful every
single year that we celebrate January
6th but just to imagine how glorious it
must have been to be there at that
blessed event that day when wise men
came from all over to to worship their
leader the true leader of us all it's
just so fitting and so right so I hope I
hope everybody is enjoying a blessed
Feast of the Epiphany and I I look
forward to it next year already on this
January 6th this glorious blessed day I
am already looking forward to January
6th next year by the time that rolls
around we might still be voting for the
speaker of the house there is no no
evidence that this is going to be
resolved anytime soon
don't forget
The Establishment told us
that this was all going to be over on
the first ballot Kevin McCarthy was the
anointed speaker he was going to get it
some of the House Freedom caucus people
could throw a fuss about it but it
didn't matter Kevin McCarthy had the
votes
and then he didn't have the votes and in
part this is because the red wave that
was supposed to take place in November
was not quite so red not quite so way
these we thought it would be
so all of a sudden McCarthy needed the
votes of those 20 members of the freedom
caucus and they were not so ready to
give up their vote since the
negotiations apparently broke down over
the summer so if you want to hear more
about the machinations behind all of
this
I conducted an interview yesterday with
my friend Lauren bobert that's on
YouTube it's on the RSS feed as well
and obviously of course on daily wire
plus so now here we are
first vote McCarthy doesn't get it
second vote he doesn't get it third vote
doesn't get it they adjourn next day one
two three he doesn't get it they adjourn
next day now we're on the 10th or 11th
ballot they're going to be voting again
today and people are pulling their hair
out this is terrible it's the downfall
of American democracy this is the fall
of our sacred democracy oh no it's
amazing that they would say that on on
January 6th amazing how history repeats
itself and yet when you look at history
it's really not all that unusual
1923 is a hundred years ago
it took nine ballots to elect a speaker
1833 90 years before that it took 10
ballots
1839 took 11 ballots
18 21 12 ballots 18 19 22 ballots 1859
44 ballots 1849 63 ballots to elect a
speaker and 1855. it took 133 ballots to
elect a speaker
this has happened before
it's okay it will be all right we will
end up with a speaker of the house it
just might not be the anointed speaker
of the house that the establishment has
rallied behind
it might not be and it's you can make
all the arguments in the world for why
Kevin McCarthy deserves it and why Kevin
McCarthy has labored in leadership for
years and years and how Kevin McCarthy
is much more conservative than John
Boehner who it's fine I'm not even
disputing those things
the job of the speaker the job of
someone in Congressional leadership is
to lead
the first test of that is can you get
enough votes to put yourself in office
if you can't
then you're probably not up to that job
now speaking of potential speaker Donald
John Trump
one consequence of this speaker fight
is it does suggest that Trump's
hold on the GOP is slipping a little bit
because Trump has vocally supported
Kevin McCarthy he is campaigned actively
for him he has called the members of the
freedom caucus who are the holdouts and
begged them to switch their vote to
McCarthy and it hasn't worked just yet
so I'm not saying that that means that
Donald Trump is not going to be the
nominee in 2024 I'm not saying that
Donald Trump is not the most important
Republican or the head of the party I'm
just saying that kind of a situation
would not have occurred in 2018. in 2018
if Trump picks up the phone tells you to
do something you're going to do it
so it means that there is a lot more at
play that the the party is not just
operating as a kind of deterministic
machine where we the people have nothing
to say about it and I think that's a
pretty good thing
if we're going to live in a Democratic
Republic
then give it to me don't give me a
facade that seems like it's a republic
but actually it's just some corrupt kind
of oligarchy give me the real thing I
want campaigning I want electioneering I
want fighting on the floor of the House
of Representatives I want Congressman
yelling at one another and wheeling and
dealing and smoking cigars and back
rooms I want all of it okay and I think
there's a reason that you saw a lot of
this in the 19th century there was a
raucous kind of democratic culture in
the 19th century some a little bit too
raucous toward the middle of the 19th
century but it was a real
period of change within the parties and
with within the relationship of the
people to their government and so I'm
all for it that's fine give it to me if
we're going to live under a democracy I
guess that's what we're going to have
now speaking of the congressman and
Democrats
Democrat representative Robert Garcia
whenever we get a Speaker of the House
plans to take the oath of office not on
a Bible
but on a comic book
representative elect Garcia has said
that he is he's issuing the Bible
he's going to swear his oath of office
on the Constitution
on his citizenship papers on a picture
of his dead parents and on a Superman
comic that he borrowed from the
government
very childish obviously to take the oath
of office on a comic it's embarrassing
it's humiliating for our whole country
and certainly for this guy
there's something deeper going on though
the the shallow take on this is just wow
this is an overgrown Man Child what a
joke or congress we're living in clown
world but there's something deeper going
on because the purpose of swearing the
oath of office is that you are swearing
by that which you worship that which you
hold most sacred that to which you feel
most accountable
the whole purpose of the oath of office
it's not just some empty ritual that we
do because people used to do it in the
old timey days we do it because what you
were saying is I promise that I will
work for the common good I'll defend the
Constitution I'll I won't be corrupt
I'll pursue good and avoid evil and I'm
swearing by my God man God help me if I
do not do that okay and so if you if you
believe in God if you believe that such
a vow matters
you're more likely to keep your promises
but for the modern lib types who don't
believe in God it's not just that then
there is a void it's that you swear by
other gods so the gods that he is
swearing by here are the gods of the
state is citizenship papers even the
Constitution the fact that he would
swear by that means that
what he holds most dear what he holds
most sacred is the state
his ancestors
and a myth I won't even just call it a
child story which Superman is but but a
myth
those that is
valuable there is Great Value in the
state there's Great Value in your
ancestors there's Great Value in myths
but it's a sorry
comparison to God
and and it's Pagan too is the other
thing in Pagan societies
in Godless societies
people swear by the state the state is
held as the Supreme thing or one's
ancestors people when they give up God
they engage in a kind of ancestor
worship or myths you think of the old
Greek and Roman myths which are
different from True Religion which
worships the one true God in a way which
is logical that's why we have theology
the the Pagan myths do not have theology
the the Pagan myths do not are not
identified with the logos you actually
see this going back all the way to the
ancient Greek writers distinguishing
between the kind of story The
mythological stories of the Gods and
the true God the truth the logic the the
the first Mover The Creator
this is a natural consequence of a
society that is giving up God and
specifically giving up Christianity
which has animated our civilization and
has allowed our civilization to become
the greatest in the history of the world
and as we give that up expect a lot more
confused people taking their oath of
office on a comic book
and and I tell you I don't want to put
the good of my Society my future my
family my state my country I'm willing
to stake that on God I am not I am not
willing to stake that on a comic book
okay I trust that God will see us
through that's where I put my trust we
write that on our money here in God we
trust that's our motto it's in the
national anthem
in Superman I do not trust
now when you want to put your faith in
God I strongly recommend you check out
the Bible into your podcast right now go
to ascensionpress.com Knowles if you're
someone who's always wanted to read and
understand the Bible but you're not sure
where to start then check out the Bible
in a year podcast from Ascension the
Bible in a year podcast is currently the
most popular religion podcast in the
United States millions of people have
listened to it and twice it's hit number
one on Apple podcasts it is the only
podcast that I reliably listen to I'm on
day 190 so it's probably going to be
more like Bible in two years for me but
you can take it at your own pace in
Bible any of your father Mike Schmitz
reads the entire Bible in 365 daily
episodes providing helpful commentary
reflection and prayer along the way what
better way to start the new year you can
find the Bible linear podcast with
father Mike Schmitz for free in your
favorite podcast app or on YouTube
unlike any other Bible podcast Bible in
a year follows a special reading plan
that organizes the books of the Bible in
a way that helps listeners understand
the story get this reading plan at
ascensionpress.com Knowles if you want
to start reading and more importantly
understanding the Bible this year go to
ascensionpress.com Knowles to download
the reading plan for free that is
ascensionpress.com Knowles to download
the reading plan for free
speaking of comic books
I don't read comic books I don't go see
the comic book movies except when the
daily wire forces me too I'm not a big
fan however I have to defend the comic
books a little bit because there's a new
hubbub over DC Comics in which
apparently it's a Batman comic I used to
really like Batman when I was a kid and
in the Batman comic the Joker who is a
man
becomes pregnant and gives birth to a
mud monster
who transforms into a child version of
the Joker and who he then adopts as his
son
apparently the some other villain
in the comic book pushes The Joker into
a big pile of mud
and the curse that this character puts
on Joker doesn't work and the Joker
becomes pregnant
and now some people are reacting and
saying this is DC Comics going woke this
is pushing the transgender agenda in our
comics and this is terrible and I
I actually have no problem with this
he's the Joker
He's the bad guy
it's it's okay I I think in artistic
depictions and certainly in mythological
depictions which is what the superhero
stories are
I think it's okay
when
disordered
experiences and desires and states of
being are represented in the bad guys I
would I would not be so Placid about it
all if Batman became pregnant that would
be pretty weird that would probably be
pushing A woke thing but yeah the Joker
is a pretty disordered guy and it's
pretty disordered for a guy to get
pregnant
I I have no problem when Milton and
Paradise Lost represents Satan as giving
birth through his head to sin and death
it's kind of trans I guess but not not
really it's okay it's a it's a
mythological depiction of something and
something that's that's quite evil and
quite disordered so I
if the comic books want to portray
transgenderism as just bizarre and wrong
and evil and something The Joker does
okay that's fine
something you should avoid now if the
Joker becomes the hero then then I guess
we have a problem speaking of gender
identity there's a group of scientists
that has just discovered
that there is no biological basis
for transgenderism
can you believe that these people get
paid to do this
can you imagine how much these
scientists got paid the funding they had
to conduct this study to know what every
three-year-old knows that's amazing but
it's good that they're doing it because
our culture is so crazy that it takes
courageous scientists to go out and buck
the politically correct Norm but this is
an international group of over 100
clinicians and researchers who have
attested that there is no biological
evidence for gender identity they've
they've observed that no Laboratory test
can distinguish a trans-identified
person from a non-trans identified
person what they write quote
the Assumption of the core biological
underpinning for gender identity and
gender dysphoria remains an unproven
Theory
while biology likely plays a role in
gender non-conformity currently there is
no brain blood or other objective test
that distinguishes a trans identified
from a non-trans identified person once
confounding factors such as sexual
orientation meaning desire are a
controlled form this is according to the
society for evidence-based gender
medicine okay I'm glad that they're
debunking this idea that you'll
sometimes hear this among the most
eccentric and incoherent transgender
activists they'll say well you know the
brain
of a man who identifies as a woman it's
actually closer to a woman's brain
which is funny because the libs for
years told us there's no difference
between the brains of men and women do
you remember that
do you remember in the days of feminism
when we were told they're absolutely no
the only differences between boys and
girls is that is a few secondary sex
characteristics but the brains are
exactly the same how dare you say that
women have different brains than men
until they wanted transgenderism and
they said no of course the brains are
totally different but there's never been
any scientific evidence for that the
reason that that some transgender
activists have made that argument is
because they're materialists and they're
atheists and they don't believe in the
soul and they don't believe in
metaphysics and so they can't discuss
these these issues of anthropology in a
sophisticated way the only thing they
can talk about is just stuff and matter
so they they have to ground the soul
which is what they're really trying to
talk about in something physical and
they know they can't ground it in the
the visible physical attributes of a
person so they say oh yeah it's
somewhere in the brain yeah somewhere in
the brain that you can't see that's
where you find out that a boy is really
a girl but that that never made sense
and the more
serious and intellectual transgender
activists will be more honest and what
they will say is there's a difference
between sex and gender
and sex is your physical state and
gender is your non-physical state so you
physically you could be a man but
metaphysically you're a woman
what they're really talking about there
is the soul
and
these guys are a little more
sophisticated and intellectual in the
way that they're talking about it but it
still doesn't hold up because then you
have to ask okay well what is the
relationship to the body and and the
soul and the relationship between the
body and the soul is that the soul is
the substantial form of the body
that the body is a symbol of the soul
and so the two are linked and the
technical term for this is hylomorphism
this is how Aristotle describes the
relationship between
form and matter between the metaphysical
stuff and the physical stuff and very
quickly not to go down a long discourse
on Ancient Greek philosophy but very
quickly this
conversation goes over the heads of the
transgender promoters because they they
want to talk about the soul when it
gives them some way of justifying their
absurd idea that a man can really be a
woman but they they don't want to go so
far as to have a serious conversation
about the soul they're not capable of
doing that because when you when you do
that when you when you raise this
possibility that the the soul is
entirely different from the body that
the soul can be in total opposition to
the body
their argument I think at that point
falls apart but then it especially falls
apart because if you're saying okay
these two things are entirely distinct
and you want to bring them into
Conformity with one another well then
that raises the obvious question okay if
my soul is one thing and my body is this
other thing
why do I have to change my body
why can't I just change my soul
why can't I just change my mind is
really the question that comes up if I
if I'm a man I look like a man and I but
my mind tells me that I'm a woman well
just change my mind I change my mind
about things all the time
I go I say hey I want sushi for lunch
and then my buddy says hey actually I
want to get burritos I say okay let's
get burritos there we go I just changed
my mind
it's very easy to change your mind it's
very hard to change your body it
requires extremely painful surgeries
extremely expensive surgeries
sterilizing yourself grafting off your
skin from your legs and your arms to
create this grotesque caricature of of
genitalia why don't you just change your
mind all of that falls apart
all of which to say getting back to the
scientific document debunking the
biological basis for gender identity
yeah obviously that's true obviously
there's no biological basis for these
sexual delusions of boys who think
they're girls it's important to
establish that
but it doesn't answer the question
the question of transgenderism is not is
it physical the question of
transgenderism is is it real
yes I know gender identity is not in
your brain somewhere it's not in your
hands it's not yes but
not every real thing is physical
love
language geometry
most things that we hold dear are not
physical but they are nonetheless real
so I I think conservatives have fallen
into this trap too and I suspect a lot
of these scientists are relatively
conservative compared to the culture and
they want to ground everything following
the Enlightenment and following the
Scientific Revolution and following
modern liberalism they want to ground
every single thing in something physical
and say well if it's not physical if I
can't see it under a microscope then
it's not real okay I guess that will
help you make certain calculations about
certain physical phenomena but most of
the stuff that we care about in the
world is not physical
we all behave every moment of every day
as if we believe that there is more to
the world than just the physical world
so then then we have to ask ourselves
okay what is the nature of the
metaphysical world and is there such a
thing as gender identity there is the
soul totally distinct from the body what
what religion are we living under okay
and and because we for most of our
country's history we took those
questions seriously and came to
relatively reasonable conclusions about
that namely
various interpretations of Christianity
some far more precise some a little less
precise but that was what animated our
country that's where our founding
fathers said that's what the men who
develop not only our country but our
civilization said okay I get that that
gives me a grounding of of who we are
and what we're all doing here together
as that has fallen apart
because of our ignorance and sin and
vice as that has fallen apart now we're
very very confused and men are chopping
off their genitals and equally confused
men are taking the oath of office and
the U.S Congress on a comic book not
great we got to turn it around or else
this country is going to die and one
thing I can tell you is we all
individually will die someday that's why
you need a will right now go to
epicwell.com use promo code at Knowles
it can be tough to stick to your New
Year's resolution you set out with lofty
goals stick to them for about two weeks
then you fall right back into your old
habits lucky for you I have a goal that
you can accomplish today complete your
will with epic will for just 119 and in
as little as five minutes epic will can
help you create your last will and
testament living will and even
Healthcare power of attorney their
step-by-step online form makes it
incredibly easy all you need to do is
fill in the blanks super duper important
I put it off for way too long
fortunately we've got it done now and it
is truly peace of mind if you got any
stuff at all all if you had any wishes
at all after you go and especially if
you have kids you got to get it done 50
of Americans do not have a will choose
today to be in the smarter half go to
epicwell.com use promo code Knowles to
save 10 on Epic Wheels complete will
package that is epicwill.com promo code
k-n-o-w-l-e-s you will die that is a
spoiler alert it's going to happen to us
all make sure you and your family are
prepared epicwell.com promo code Knowles
speaking of our advertisers and speaking
of getting back to Christianity
Bible in a year which you've heard me
mention on the show many times heard me
mention today
Bible in a year remains one of the top
podcasts in the country
Bible in a year right now is the number
three podcast in the country according
to the charts
do you know what the number two podcast
is
the Bible recap which is another Bible
podcast this one put out by D group
do you know what the number one podcast
in the country is
catechism in a year also with father
Mike Schmitz who does Bible linear
this one Catholic priest is the host of
two of the three most popular podcasts
in the country
one of which is on the Bible one of
which is on the catechism of the
Catholic Church
and then the podcast that's wedged right
in the middle of those two is the top
three
is also a Bible podcast this is great
news I know there's all terrible news in
the culture and in the politics
this is great news
what that tells me is not
that our country is totally fine right
now
not that actually we're still a serious
Christian country that has our act
together it doesn't tell me that
but it tells me that there is a longing
in the country
to return to that which is true and good
and beautiful
there is a long we're not there right
now
if we lived in a country that had its
act together
spiritually personally politically
I suspect that Bible in a year and
catechism in a year probably wouldn't be
the top three podcasts
I suspect there you you might have some
religion shows as the top podcast you
might have you might it might be father
Mike Schmitz but they would be they
would be more advanced they would be on
the lives of the Saints they would be on
the doctors of the church they would be
on on more
technical aspects of the faith I think
probably because we would all we would
all know our Bible really really well we
would all know the catechism really
really well
the Bible in your podcast is I mean it's
edifying for people who've been in the
church their whole lives but it's also
totally acceptable to people who are
just questioning who don't even know
what they believe catechism in a year is
the is that primer okay what does it
mean to be in the church what does the
church say what is the church taught for
2000 years it's
it's totally open and accessible and can
be very basic for people which is a
wonderful thing because it's people who
have been raised basically without
religion
who recognize wow
something has gone horribly wrong here
some whatever I don't know what it was
but something broke in the last 70 years
and I want to I want to get back to that
thing that we lost that's one that's
absolutely great news speaking of
enduring things the oldest woman that
had been living in America just died
she died at the age of 115 and according
to nurses her final words were
I have information that will lead to the
arrest of Hillary Clinton
it's true no that's not that part's not
true but the oldest woman the oldest
living woman in America did die 115
years old and her actual last words were
not I hope we're not about Hillary
Clinton I don't know her actual last
words though it seems were
about hard work
in the later years not her very final
breath that she uttered but in the final
years of her life people kept asking her
how did you live so long and and she
kept going back to this answer hard work
and the love of my family and good genes
and all of this but you know working
hard and this is really really
important for us to remember because a
lot of people in our modern culture
believe that the reason that we go to
work
is so that we can have the weekends for
your career the reason that you go
trudge along all day it's your job that
maybe you like it but maybe probably
more likely you don't like your job all
that much the reason that you do it is
because you have to do it to make a
little bit of money so you can get to
the weekend and then you can watch some
TV and you can chill out and eat some
potato chips and then you got to go to
work again on Monday and we're going to
do that for
50 years and then
maybe if we're lucky we get to quit our
jobs and sit on the couch and eat potato
chips until we die
and that view we're all tempted by it at
different times but that view is not in
accordance with our nature
we are made to work
ever since Adam took that fateful bite
we the humanity has been kicked out of
the Garden of Eden and by the sweat of
our brow will we earn our food and and
it is it is good some people
in my family and friends have done just
fine in retirement
more often than not people go crazy in
retirement and there are statistics on
this that people very often will die
shortly after they retire
because they lose a sense of meaning and
purpose we are meant to work
and there's there's even a strange
phenomenon that I I have even noticed in
the new year which is that in the lead
up to the holidays
people usually slack off a little bit
people stop showing up to work as much
you kind of slowed down okay we'll get
started again and then you hit the
ground running at the beginning of
January and what's weird is I have found
during the periods in my life where I'm
slacking off a little bit
I'm I'm far less energetic maybe I'm
sleeping more maybe I'm relaxing more
but I'm I have lower energy
than when I'm working hard and not
sleeping that much and I've got a
thousand things that I've got to do we
are meant to work take that advice from
the oldest woman in America I'm not
saying you got to just put all your
efforts to trudging away in the widget
Factory or something far from that
but you're working for your boss to make
your paycheck and you're working for
your family
and then you're working for God there's
a reason that there is that old Maxim
that we all know is true in our lives
Idle Hands Are The Devil's Playground do
not be
idle okay I wouldn't people write in all
the time about vices that they have
they'll say oh I've been an alcoholic uh
the main one that people write in about
is porn or the hookup culture because
sex is so Central to our nature they'll
say oh I was addicted to drugs or I'm
addicted to social media or oh I'm
addicted to that what's the common
thread here
the Common Thread to all of those things
is that you do them when you're not
doing anything else that's when we just
sit around and doom scroll
so you got to work and it's a new year
and people make all sorts of resolutions
that they immediately break but when you
look ahead to the year you have to ask
yourself what are we doing what are we
going to do frankly I see this reflected
in the leadership fight
as I've said I'm not a member of
Congress I don't as far as political
battles go this one is not super high up
on my list I think leadership fights
really are just for the members to
decide and they involve a lot more than
political issues
but I like seeing this fight I am glad
that the Republicans are not just
sleepwalking idly into well this is what
we're told we're going to do and we
don't really have any say over it anyway
and so we're just going to keep on doing
the same old thing okay I'm gonna go do
my TV show hit and then I'm going to go
back and fundraise and okay whatever no
I'm I want to see my Representatives
engaged in real fights getting real
concessions out of one another talking
about real issues that is not a bug of
our system that is a feature last year
Jordan Peterson joined daily wire Plus
he has been putting the rest of us to
shame with his output you want to talk
about energy that guy is like the
Energizer Bunny seems like every day
there's something new from Jordan and it
is very high quality too specials such
as logos and literacy a special on
marriage and brand new episodes of the
biblical series Exodus
as I am speaking Jordan right now is
probably recording something new for us
if you want to see it you have got to
become a member because you will only
find it on daily wire plus so head on
over to dailywire.com Knowles to become
a member and watch all of this and more
that is dailywire.com Knowles today
finally finally we have arrived for the
first time in the new year at my
absolute favorite day of the week
that would be mailbag day let's take it
away with the voicemail bag
hello there soon to be Speaker of the
House Michael Knowles I listen to your
show pretty much every single day of my
life and I hardly ever disagree with you
but the other day you brought up New
York's new burial composting law and you
said that it's a degradation that is
disrespectful to the dead that we
absolutely shouldn't do it but as a
conservative guy myself I've always
thought that that's the right thing to
do I've always wondered why do we pump
bodies full of formaldehyde why do we
screw their jaws shut why do we bury
people in concrete tombs to preserve
them forever it just doesn't make any
sense to me it seems that that the
natural thing that God desired was for
us to return our bodies back to the
Earth to to give back to his creation so
that future Generations can have the
nutrients the earth needs so where's the
disconnect here
thanks
the question I would ask you first of
all thank you not only for listening to
the show but for your
clear wisdom on who the next speaker of
the house should be not that I would
ever want okay not that I've not I've
never sought that office I would only
accept it if the congressman elected me
to it
the question you have to ask yourself on
the composting is
why do you believe that God intended for
us to be thrown into the garden and have
tomatoes grow out of us you said it
seems to me that God just wanted this to
happen okay why do you believe that
is there a scriptural basis for why you
believe that
probably not
is there a basis in the tradition of the
church that would have you believe that
certainly not
why do you believe that maybe you
believe it because
God says remember man that thou art dust
and unto us Thou shalt return yeah
that's certainly true but that's true
whether you're put in a coffin or
whether you're thrown to the dogs in the
garden or or chopped up like mulch
you will return to us that's just a fact
of the physical world the question is
how do we treat dead bodies do we treat
them
as the remains of
people made in the image and likeness of
God and beloved family members and with
some reverence with some respect or do
we treat them like fertilizer
the the composting law chooses the
latter category
the the composting law is based on a
an anthropology that denies the soul I
think that at least implicitly denies
the soul
it's based on
a theology that is not Christian at the
very least I think we would say there
have been other religions in history
that throw people to the dogs
Zoroastrianism would throw people to
vultures or to the dogs but but that's
not our view that's a different that's a
different religious View and and so
I don't think that you need to embalm
the dead I don't think you need to pump
them full of formaldehyde or put them in
special makeup or put them build a giant
Mausoleum for them but I do think that
we need to treat dead bodies with
respect and reverence and we shouldn't
just
intentionally accelerate the process of
them turning into tomatoes so that we
can eat them in some bizarre Pagan
ritual like like cannibal indigenous
people do where they where they'll eat a
piece of their relatives or something
that would be disordered and
disrespectful I think and and likewise I
don't think that we should burn our dead
either it's certainly less egregious and
events than than composting them but I
also think it's quite Pagan to burn the
dead I think it makes a mockery of the
idea of the resurrection of the body
next question
hi Michael Arun here you recently
explained objective reality as not being
the only aspect of reality uh for
example you explained that the sun may
be the center of the solar system for
the purpose of calculation but in a very
real sense the Earth is really the
center of the solar system now I like
this idea and I agree that we may give a
bit too much Primacy to the idea of
objective reality as opposed to I guess
metaphysical reality but what do we do
about the truth claims that are made by
various religions uh just to use an
example from your faith Saint Paul says
that Jesus is risen from the dead in a
real sense and if he is not then your
faith is in vain so my question for you
is do you believe that Jesus is risen
from the dead in the same sense that the
sun is the center of the solar system or
in the same sense that the Earth is the
center I think this will help me to much
better understand this distinct between
objective reality and metaphysical
reality thank you as always for your
wisdom
Arun continuing to prove yourself one of
my absolute favorite members of the
Michael Knowles show and a really really
intelligent question not that we would
expect anything less a little bit of a
correction here though
I think you're falling into the language
trap that I'm trying to avoid which is
conflating scientific reality or
physical observation with objective
reality and and I think certain things
can be objectively perceived
in physical reality but certain things
are also objectively true metaphysically
so I I wouldn't I wouldn't say that the
physical world is that's the objective
reality in the metaphysical world is
subjective that's actually the thing
that I'm arguing against but the rest of
your question I think
uh acknowledges that that fact so uh the
point as as you summarized it is
yeah it's true that when I look up in
this when I look up and I make some
calculations and I I make some
scientific experiments about the
physical world I can discover that the
Earth revolves around the Sun
so that means the Earth is not at the
center of the solar system or the center
of the universe but metaphysically
speaking because man is the meeting of
the physical body with with the rational
soul man is in a deeper sense the center
of the cosmos so which is it is man the
center of the universe or not well
because metaphysical reality is more
fundamental Than Physical reality
physical reality is contingent on
metaphysical reality that's why it's
metaphysical it's beyond physics I I
think it is truer and more profound to
say that man is the center of the
universe but for the purposes of making
certain physical calculations I think
it's fair enough to say that the Earth
revolves around the Sun now you ask
about
My Religion what about the resurrection
of Christ is that metaphysically true in
some sense is a kind of a really nice
metaphor but not it didn't actually
physically happen or did it physically
happen it's not a metaphor but it
physically happens
in the person of Christ you see uniquely
the perfect meeting of the physical and
the metaphysical they are both true
simultaneously in Christ God Christ is
fully man and fully God
he
metaphorically feeds five thousand
people with just a few loaves of bread
he also literally fed five thousand
people with just loaves of bread he
metaphorically turns the water of of
ritual into the wine of Celebration and
marriage he also literally did that he
metaphysically
saves us or metaphorically saves us
metaphorically rises from the dead and
resurrected that also physically
happened in Christ it has to be the
perfect meeting earlier on in the show I
I talked about
the silliness of taking the oath of
office on a Superman comic and pointed
out that this is kind of a pagan
practice that the Pagan myths are just
myths what distinguishes the Pagan myths
from the Christian story
even even according to the
self-understanding of the pagans in most
cases
the myths
are metaphorical
Christianity is the true myth
the myths are
partake of literary genres such as
poetry or Fort myth I guess or fable
Christianity the gospels are journalism
along with all the other genre too but
it's journalism it's this man
at this time did these miraculous things
and these other physical men who were
born in bodies and dates and times in a
real place actually saw them happen and
there were 500 eyewitnesses to the
resurrection and there were 12 Apostles
and they went all around the world and
they spread this thing that actively
actually happened in Christ and in the
sacraments that he institutes we see
this perfect meeting of the physical and
the metaphysical next question greetings
to you Nostradamus from the Rio Grande
Valley
often you discuss how men ought to be
men how we should be leaders for our
families and that as men of faith and
good character we should exercise with
discretion executive Authority in our
relationship or marriage where if any
have you made concessions with your wife
and why also do you have tattoos thanks
love the show
I only have tattoos when I'm playing
guitar at the Ryman that's that's when I
have tattoos the rest of the time I do
not have tattoos how does that work well
it's a profound physical and
metaphysical conundrum which I'm sure we
can explore at some other time in terms
of making concessions to your wife of
course we all make concessions to our
wife I've certainly done that uh and and
when I think of my day-to-day life sweet
little Elisa
makes most of the decisions
ultimately I guess I'm the decider to
quote George W bush but practically
speaking
Elisa makes most of these what are we
going to have for dinner where are we
going this weekend what are what are the
kids wearing what am I wearing frankly
you know she makes
most of those decisions uh but because
the husband is the head of household and
man is the head of wife a husband is
that of a wife as Christ as out of the
church there is this leadership role
within a marriage so what does that look
like in practice
well one decision where Lisa and I were
not did not totally see eye to eye and I
just delegated it to Elisa because why
not was our bedroom furniture
our bedroom furniture is a little it's a
little more modern than I like it's
still pretty Trad but you know Elisa she
look she spends most
more time than I do in the bedroom
she doesn't spend most of her time in
the bedroom but she spends more time
than I do because she's there with the
babies and she's that in the home and so
that's okay if she has a vision for how
the bedroom's going to look okay that's
fine rest of the house where I spend
more time
I I had a little bit more to say about
those things
but beyond these little disputes that
are inevitably going to arise in any
marriage because two people are
different
I think the more important thing is
that not only do you have to
compromise and you get this room and I
get this room and you got this dinner
now we're going to this place and now
this you you actually
you want to mold your Wills to be in
accord with one another
it's it's not merely that you need to
come to some kind of contractual
conclusion about the particular things
you're going to do
you marriage is also about transforming
the will
so that your your desires are actually
ever closer to one another I mean that
is how you become
that is how you become one flesh
more and more so over time and this is
also by the way to get back to the
analogy that marriage is marriage is a
symbol of the relationship between
Christ and his church
you broadly you and your wife in your
marriage in your whole church want
Evermore to conform your will to God's
will so it's not just that you want that
you're going to do the things that God
tells you to do grudgingly but you
actually want to cultivate the desire to
do what God wants you to do and you want
to Tamp down the desire to do things
that are contrary to God's will I mean
this is of all the beautiful images in
Dante's comedy in The Divine Comedy this
to me is the the most profound and
enduring and transformative which is
that you're you're actually turning your
will
toward God who's whose will is
the love that moves the the sun and the
other stars next question hey swarthy
Mike it's Demars from Arizona and I have
a dating slash relationship question for
you I am a young college age girl I'm
very religious and I don't hide that or
make a point to hide it I tend to be
very modest in my dress and my behavior
and my thinking into my speech
and by all of today's standards uh it
would seem that I would be considered
outdated and obscure with that in mind I
know you get a lot of questions about
what girls look for in guys but I really
like your perspective on what does a guy
look or find most attractive in a woman
and maybe more specifically a religious
woman I'd love to hear your thoughts
thank you so much for all you do thank
you for the show and proud to be a creme
de La Creme for the rest of my life
wonderful to to hear from you thank you
for writing in
I'm glad you specified at the end what
does a guy look for in a religious girl
because
when you say what does a guy look for in
a girl I think you got to be a little
more specific you got to be more
specific about the guy his perspective
time of life what's he looking for
exactly what's he looking for in a Girl
Like You Damaris I think
what one would look for is a serious
woman
you can be you should be fun you should
make yourself look pretty as one does
this you know you should do all of the
kind of normal things that go along with
dating but one thing that I always found
to be a real turn off with women and I
continue to find to be a turn off with
women even though I'm not on the market
anymore I still chat with plenty of
women and the one thing that I really I
just think oh how ugh get this lady away
from me is when women play a lot of
games you know when they're all sort of
just trying to play these little
frivolous sort of games I I find that in
in just my daily life very off-putting
and certainly in my dating life when I
was single I found this very very
off-putting and the thing there are many
things that I love about sweet little
Elisa but one of them in particular is
sweet little Elisa she's a serious girl
okay
she's one of if not the funniest woman I
have ever met
which I I do find important actually and
one of if not the most perceptive women
that I've ever met but she's she takes
herself seriously she isn't she isn't
Blown Away on fads and games and
passions I find that to be really really
important okay and when you look at
depictions of Love particularly from the
the courtly love tradition where
when we think about the literary
tradition of love this is really where
we take it from Middle Ages that is what
these women are like I mean these women
are serious women when you lie just
mentioned Dante when you look at Dante's
great love Beatrice Beatrice is a
serious woman
okay who is beautiful and graceful and
feminine in all of these things and also
when Dante steps out of line she kind of
gives him a look
you know and when Dante starts crying at
the end of purgatory because he's about
to lose his buddy Virgil his guide
throughout throughout hell and Purgatory
she goes hey
stop crying we gotta go we gotta go up
to heaven we gotta go to God
that's something to look for just be
Beatrice is that so hard the rest of the
show continues now
you do not want to miss it become a
member right now it is fake headline
Friday I need your help to to guide me
along as Virgil guided Dante as I try to
discern which of the five headlines my
producer Ben Davies has given me is the
fake headlines so head on over diy.com
use code Knowles at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans daily
wire.com Knowles
[Music]
foreign
[Music]